ça va faire il ya des faux public et
c'est donc ce que même des gens chez eux
ils regardent de ces jeux vocaux match
du jour et c'est quoi ce blouson de fous
que tu m'as mis hier sur l'émission
là-bas ces mêmes personnes qui s'est
mise à entonner incroyable incroyable
j'ai fait une capture d'écran j'ai je
veux jouer sur deux jeunes intérieurs
[Rires]
booba merci d'être là je sais que je
suis très très heureux de te voir et tu
sais que voilà j'aime tesson j'aime ce
que tu fais oui si on te qui c'est la
troisième fois que tu viens et je suis
toujours aussi content de te voir
l'album moi ça la chance de recevoir
l'album c'est un événement tu vas nous
voir parce qu'il va sortir ce soir à
minuit
ultra regarder ça c'est magnifique 2002
2021 je n'ai même pas ça va encore ça va
falloir commandé par commander ce soir à
minuit ultra c'est ce que si tu te rends
compte qu'à chaque fois des albums comme
ils sont attendus
c'est un truc de fou non mais ce sont
les 20 ans de carrière et sont toujours
aussi attendu comme toys émission matin
en amont je suis un imbécile mais on
travaille dur mais tu es dieu on est
habitué à zéro défaite donc ça t'en
étais fier très fier fier et soulagé
ben je sens que ça va être une tuerie je
pense c'est vrai que quand tu dis que ça
va être le dernier ou pas assez ou c'est
non c'est vrai ces derniers dixièmes
sight avait pris feu avant un avait
prévu avant que ce serait le dernier ou
parles-tu t18 là où je pensais que
c'était le bon moment c'est le dixième
j'ai donné ce que j'avais à donner j'ai
fait beaucoup de nos fêtes de guerre
ouais je pense que c'est le temps de se
reposer transmettre et plus passer plus
de temps à la production etc
non mais t'as vu qu'il fait c'est sans
regret mais si toi tu prêt mais tu sais
que les gens et ils vont me demander des
montants demandés l'autre les gens les
gens m'a même moi j'ai envie de monter
encore alors je vais écouter le dixième
album mais tu sais que mon vrai ça c'est
fou quelqu'un qui regarde
ici par sos il voit vous pas regardé une
émission peut faire le plan cette jeune
fille et qui est en train de pleurer
parce qu'elles sont c'est incroyable
c'est trop chou franchement j'aurais
aimé qu'on l'a vite tu vois sur le
plateau combinant plus non mais sa tête
est à toi j'en ai fait d'un mexicain
je voudrais qu'on voit le clip avec j ai
6 mona lisa ce soir minuit
l'album toi tu sais que sur les réseaux
je sais très bien qu'on ce soir à minuit
ça va être la folie comme d'habitude
métier que je suis comme un fou parce
que je cherche un tu veux que je te dise
tu sais pourquoi je vois que je t'aime à
chaque fois que tu seras un truc tu sais
comme quand un enfant qui sans un truc
ou un pote ou un frère j'ai envie je me
dis j'espère que ça va tout cartonner et
à chaque fois je te vois tu étais je te
vois partout donc je suis très content
pour leur influence directe est que là
tu sens que tu as travaillé comme un fou
sur celui-là d'accord ouais je sais que
tu as raison à 9 heures mais il faut
savoir que le mec qui dort clamé un truc
nouveau parce que moi des faits parfois
je l'appelle j'oublie qu'il ya un
décalage mais il est toujours en studio
en train de travailler dans mais tu
travailles comment ouf comme temps
sait-on qu'il n'y a pas de combat et
puis y'a pas de secret le talent c'est
bien mais quand elle jurait autant
autant faut travailler
regardez et 1,6 numéro 10 madonna mais
l'espoir faut toucher du bois
abus de pouvoir chez moi serait pas
l'équipement
en contrôlant
cocaïne
intuit code pour la crète hommes étaient
moins de mona lisa
faudra les fumeurs
un retour
on m'a pris deux ans
ray contre l'ebre
j'ai tellement loin
retour en mauve en pétrole mines est
d'emmener leur dada
[Musique]
attends pas triché au sommaire comme ton
chaque y échangent pas qu'elle
[Musique]
je demande